ah non j'ai toujours été un grand rêveur
parce que je pense sincèrement que la
vie est faite pour rêver et que les
rêves sont faits pour être réalisés
lorsque l'on est enfant on a souvent des
rêves plein la tête et beaucoup de gens
finissent par les abandonnés par peur et
par conformisme et il est évident que
pour réaliser ses rêves dans la vie il
est important de sortir de sa zone de
confort il est important de s'exposer de
se mettre en danger et c'est là où la
magie opère c'est là où vous pouvez
faire de votre vie quelque chose
d'extraordinaire moi quand j'étais
enfant j'étais j'ai été fasciné par le
magicien d'oz alors est ce que vous
connaissez l'histoire du magicien d'oz
moi je vais vouloir rappeler brièvement
donc c'est l'histoire de d'une jeune
fille qui s'appelle dorothée et qui est
emporté par une tornade et qui atterrit
dans un dans un pays imaginaire peuplé
de deux sorcières et de magiciens et
pour rentrer chez elle elle a besoin de
l'aide d'un magicien qui est le magicien
d'oz et ce magicien habite dans un
palais au bout d'une route de briques
jaunes donc elle décide d'emprunter
cette route de briques jeune et elle va
rencontrer des personnages hauts en
couleur comme un épouvantail qui qui se
plaint de ne pas avoir de cerveau
un bûcheron en fer blanc qui lui se
plaint de ne pas avoir de coeur et un
lion qui se plaint de manquer de courage
et ensembles dont vu des aventures
extraordinaires et moi j'aurais tout
donné pour vivre des aventures comme
celle plus tard lorsque j'ai lorsque
j'avais à peu près 17 ans on m'a demandé
ce que je voulais faire dans la vie
moi tout naturellement je rêvais je
répondais à cette question' ment en
disant ben moi je veux réaliser mes
rêves je veux voyager je vais découvrir
le monde je vais découvrir d'autres
cultures
je veux rencontrer des gens et vivent
des aventures et à chaque fois on me
répondait mais c'est pas un métier ça on
me répondait arrêtent de rêver redescend
sur terre arrêtent de rêver je pense que
c'est une phrase que vous avez déjà dû
entendre dans au moins une fois dans
votre vie et bien souvent à les
prononcer justement par des gens qui qui
ont abandonné leur rêve depuis longtemps
plus tard lorsque j'avais 25 ans donc je
lisais beaucoup de livres d'aventuriers
d'explorateurs des gens qui avaient
vraiment choisi de vivre leur rêve qui
m'inspiraient énormément et parmi mes
lectures je suis tombé sur un livre qui
m'a particulièrement marqué qui est un
livre de serge et nicole repli la terre
à en perdre la boule
alors c'est l'histoire d'un couple serge
et nicole qui qui ont fait le tour du
monde mais ils l'ont fait d'une manière
particulière puisque serge l'a fait
intégralement au courant et samassa m'a
vraiment marqué tout simplement parce
que c'était c'était quelque chose que je
rêvais de faire quelque chose qui était
sur balises de rêve que j'ai une liste
de rêve j'ai une liste de choses que je
veux que je vois tout près à complaire
dans ma vie et il s'en faisait partie
donc je me suis dit ben il faut à tout
prix que je raconte serge donc je me
suis arrangée pour récupérer ses
coordonnées et je les a pris et là il
m'a appris que quelques semaines plus
tard il donnait une conférence un peu
comme celle ci à vichy donc je suis
originaire de dunkerque 1 j'habite
dunkerque et je me suis dit bon ok ben
je vais déjà commencer par là je vais
aller au guichet en courant
à l'époque j'avais j'avais encore jamais
couru de marathon je faisais déjà
beaucoup de sport vous imaginez j'étais
déjà sapeur pompier professionnel à
dunkerque et donc je suis parti comme ça
et j'ai fait 70 km par jour en une
dizaine de jours donc les 700 km et je
suis arrivé à vichy où j'ai rencontré
serge à l'issue de cette conférence j'ai
vraiment été passionné par par le
personnage est pareil parce qu'il avait
fait et je voulais tout comme le
magicien d'oz tout comme dorothée vivre
une aventure comme celle qui l'a qu'il
avait qu'il avait vécu et j'ai dit à ma
femme écoute il faut qu'on fasse quelque
chose maintenant c'est ici maintenant
que ça se passe il faut qu'on parte
elle m'a dit ok très bien où on va et
judy mais l écoute on va au bout du
monde et je croyais pas si bien dire
puisque j'avais eu un autre livre de de
mike horn qui lui a fait le tour du
monde à pied également mais par le
cercle polaire et il était parti du cap
nord en norvège et j'avais lu que le cap
nord en norvège c'était vraiment le bout
du monde puisque c'est là c'est la ville
la plus au nord
après deux caps n'ont rien à rien si ce
n'est le pôle nord je me suis dit je
vais partir du pôle nord et quand je
voulais faire quelque chose qui n'avait
encore jamais été fait jeudi je vais
partir en plein hiver quand on part en
plein hiver du cap nord c des
températures de - 40 moins 45 degrés des
conditions assez extrêmes et donc à
partir du moment où on avait notre notre
point de départ on s'est dit on va
partir du d'un point symbolique on va
arriver un autre point symbolique
on s'est dit bon on va aller jusqu'à
gibraltar on a donc été acheté une carte
de l'europe et un à tracer un itinéraire
alors cet itinéraire comme vous pouvez
le voir il est pas tout à fait direct
puisque en fait ce qui nous ce qui nous
ce qui nous importait c'était pas trop
la destination est finalement deux
heures de voyage c'est pas la
destination qui compte c'est le voyage
en lui-même c'est les rencontres et c
c'est le partage qu'on allait pouvoir
avoir dans cette dans ce périple
on avait juste une contrainte c'est que
comme on partait du cap nord en plein
hiver polaire il fallait pour raison de
sécurité qu'on un engin motorisé
donc on a décidé donc les conques
repasserait par dunkerque d'ailleurs
vous voyez sur la carte et que donc
laetitia donc on épouse prendrait le
quad sur la première partie par raisons
de sécurité je vous expliquerai
d'ailleurs que ça nous a bien servi et
ensuite à dunkerque elle changerait le
prendre le vélo pour la suite du périple
et ensuite on s'est dit c'est bien de
voyages et de réaliser notre rêve mais
ce serait bien qu'on le fasse pour une
cause qui nous tiennent à coeur
tout simplement parce que le fait de
faire tourner seul pour quelque chose
qui nous tiennent à coeur
ça va surtout nous permettre dans les
moments difficiles de ne jamais
abandonner de se rattacher à quelque
chose et d'être engagé pour quelqu'un
d'être engagé pour quelque chose pas
uniquement pour soi même donc on a créé
une association qui s'appelle coureurs
de rêve et qui a pour but par le biais
des défis sportifs que je peux réaliser
avec mon épouse de ré de récolter des
fonds pour réaliser le rêve d'enfants
malades
c'est à dire que en réalisant notre rêve
on pouvait réaliser le rêve d'autres
personnes et peut-être inspiré ces ses
enfants et les soutenir dans leur
maladie alors ensuite il fallait nous
financer nous personnellement puisque on
partait pendant neuf mois ont quitté nos
emplois
et donc voilà donc on a commencé à créer
comment on a on a créé un dossier un
dossier pour pouvoir aller chercher des
sponsors tout simplement et là on a eu
la surprise parce que je pensais qu'à
grands rêveurs allez allez allez
forcément inspiré des gens qu'on allait
forcément avoir des gens avec nous et en
fait le type de réaction qu'on a eu
c'est celle ci on a beaucoup de gens qui
se sont énormément manqué de nous parce
que tout simplement ils pensaient que
c'était pas possible ça n'avait jamais
été fait on pouvait pas courir à -45
degrés surtout qu'on avait aucun aucun
point d'attachement dormait dans une
tente on devait se débrouiller en
autonomie totale surtout dans les nier
en laponie où il ya rien n'est que de
l'année j'ai des ours et
on s'est dit aussi donc la voyez bon là
on au cap nord pas si cela aide un peu
trop vite et finalement on a pour nom
fini pour se financer on n'a pas attendu
tous les feux soient au vert
on a vendu pas mal de nos biens
personnels notre voiture puisque on en
aurait de toute façon plus besoin et
comme vous voyez le 12 janvier 2007 on
était au cap nord je faisais mes
premières foulées par moins 25 degrés il
faisait chaud ce jour là en plénière
envoyer les 14 heures il fait nuit il
fait la nuit complète en plein hiver et
donc voilà nos praticiens n'ai pas pu me
suivre cette première partie puisque la
route était bloquée officiellement je
pouvais pas courir on avait dû
parlementer avec les autorités
norvégiennes pour qu'ils me laissent
courir à condition qu'ils aient un
véhicule de sécurité des autorités qui
nous suivent donc voilà alors ensuite on
a passé une première
une première semaine
un peu compliqué parce que effectivement
fallait se régler sur pas mal de choses
pendant des cons et en autonomie on
avait nos provisions d'eau qui gelé donc
on avait pas d'eau un certain moment
notre nourriture jeu légalement donc
j'ai d'ailleurs je me suis cassé une
dent j'en ai perdu
et voilà bon la première semaine c'est
quand même plus ou moins bien passé
jusque septième jour où là je vous
disais que le quoi nous avait servi le
septième jour j'ai alors le septième
jour j'ai eu un petit souci c'est qu'on
avait l'habitude au cap nord la route
qui mène au cap nord est
comment et vous êtes vous avez certains
bars qui sont qui sont réparties comme
ça tout le long de la route et pas
d'habitation mais vous avez débarque
pour les routiers puisque le cap nord
est habitée donc ils ont besoin de
provisions et on avait l'habitude de
s'arrêter dans un bar de routier avant
d'installer notre campement pour se
permettre déjà de se réchauffer de
passer des vêtements secs et de pouvoir
de pouvoir se restaurer et ce jour là
c'était acquis lots jacky en norvège
exactement qui est un lieu digne a rien
fait à part un bar et quand je suis
arrivé devant le bar le bar était fermé
le problème c'est que il faisait moins
40 ou moins 45 degrés ce jour là et que
quand je m'arrêtais de courir il était
il était vraiment impératif que je
continue de courir tout le temps puisque
la seule lors de mon corps me permettait
d'être à température et quelques minutes
d'arrêt me geler sur place
je suis arrivé devant la porte et
j'étais littéralement gelé jeu plus un
peu plus possible de bouger complètement
paralysé et la laetitia percuté
immédiatement elle m'a déshabillée m'a
passé des vêtements secs m'a mis sur le
quad et a roulé pendant quarante
kilomètres jusqu'à la première
habitation et 7
première habitation donc c'était des
lapons et qui m'ont réveillé d'une
manière assez originale puisqu'ils m'ont
servi un café avec sept cafés et à peu
près ça de vodka donc du coup je vous
cache pas j'ai été réveillée très vite
et donc à l'issue de cet épisode le
lendemain on est reparti du point où on
s'était arrêté puisque je tenais à
courir tous les kilomètres et à partir
de là la presse s'est intéressée à nous
notamment la presse la presse
finlandaise à la pasta landaise on a
fait la une des journaux la basse et ça
ce qui nous a permis de récolter les
premiers fonds pour les enfants malades
on a été aussi logés dans les casernes
de pompiers puisqu'il ya une solidarité
qui s'est faite par ça donc on a pu on a
pu pour récupérer un peu le soir et pas
dormir sous des températures assez
extrêmes
et donc voilà donc c'était vraiment une
aventure fantastique en laponie ensuite
notre périple à continuer plus ou moins
sans encombre avec des rencontres
exceptionnelles dont notamment une
lorsqu'on est arrivé en pologne
voilà la personne que vous voyez là avec
qui je bois une bière c'est marius alors
marius c'est quelqu'un d'exceptionnel
c'est un peu le bûcheron du magicien
d'oz mais lui avec un coeur énorme
on l'a rencontrée par hasard lorsqu'on
passait la frontière lituanienne pour la
pologne est en fait il est
marionnettiste y donne des spectacles
dans les écoles et elissa arrangé pour
pour pour nous suivre sur toute la
traversée de la pologne pour donner ses
spectacles dans les villes où on passait
et il s'arrangeait pour nous héberger à
chaque fois c'était vraiment une
aventure humaine exceptionnelle en
pologne puisque les gens étaient
vraiment d'un accueil d'un accueil
extraordinaire quoi je dois dire que
c'est vraiment un pays qui m'a qui m'a
marqué pour ça c'est aussi en pologne
d'ailleurs qu'on a récolté assez de
fonds pour pouvoir réaliser le premier
rêve d'enfant malade qui était d'acheter
un cheval pour marielle une jeune fille
qui avait la mucoviscidose donc là notre
voyage prenez vraiment un sens et ça
nous a poussé vraiment aller 1
continuez de toute façon on n'avait pas
on n'avait pas trop le choix et
pas voilà c'était vraiment c'était
vraiment exceptionnel de ce côté là on
arrivait après dunkerque où beaucoup de
gens nous attendaient à la frontière
alors ça aussi c'est un souvenir
exceptionnel et c'est aussi surtout le
passage où laëtitia prenez le vélo donc
là c'était vraiment un peu dur pour elle
faut savoir qu'elle tirait une charrette
où il y avait 70 kg de bagages et la
difficulté c'est qu'elle était restée un
peu inactif pendant quatre mille cinq
cents kilomètres pendant que moi je
courais donc cvc pourraient ça a été un
peu plus compliqué mais après bon c'est
comme tout il a réussi 60 j'étais là
pour eux pour que ça marche
alors on a continué notre notre périple
on devait monter le mont blanc on n'a
pas pu à cause des conditions météo nous
je suis pas allé au bout du monde du
mont blanc
je suis arrêté à mi chemin une autre
difficulté a été l'italie alors pour
plusieurs raisons est la première
c'était le comportement routier des
italiens et surtout l'état des routes
enfin la configuration des routes
puisqu'on a fait toute la corniche
italienne c'était vraiment très
dangereux j'avoue qu'on s'est fait peur
plus d'une fois
surtout j'ai eu surtout plus peur pour
laetitia puisque moi je pouvais aller
mitsou été très facilement sur le bas
côté
elles n'ont donc ça a vraiment été un
peu compliqué de ce côté là puis on
avait surtout les premières chaleurs et
les premières chaleurs ont surtout était
très importante en sicile parce que
comme vous l'avez vu sur le sur le
périple je passais par la sicile où là
on avait 47 degrés à palerme ce qui
faisait un différentiel de 92 degrés par
rapport à la température la plus froide
on allait jusqu'à boire 18 litres d'eau
par jour donc il fallait vraiment se
ravitailler il y avait tout le
il y avait tout souci logistique qui
était qui est également important
ensuite j'ai rattrapé le sud de la
france et au sud de la france ben c'est
à dire je vous parle que des difficultés
mais c'est ça qui faisait la richesse du
périple
lorsqu'on est arrivé dans le sud de la
france tombés malades entre
entre nice et montpellier sans doute
trop de courses entre de course à pied
je commençais à uriner un peu de sang je
vomissais j'ai fait quelques bilans
l'hôpital est en fait tout était plus ou
moins normal quoi enfin plus ou moins
drôle pour quelqu'un qui compte que 50
km par jour
et finalement on a donc continué plus ou
moins sans encombre alors toujours avec
des rencontres exceptionnelles les
casernes de pompiers il ya une
solidarité
d'ailleurs c'est la sainte barbe
aujourd'hui c'est la fête des pompiers
et
gérer les rejoindre après vous inquiétez
pas et donc
et voilà il donc on a traversé donc
l'espagne aussi avec des rencontres
exceptionnelles au niveau des hauts
niveaux des pompiers la chaleur un pays
aussi qui était qui était très très
accueillants pour pour nous et surtout
donc la voyez là c'est des images c'est
des images du sud de l'espagne
d-wade du sud de l'espagne on est près
d'arriver et le 24 septembre 2007 donc
250 jours jour pour jour après qu'on
soit parti on est donc arrivé à
gibraltar
alors surtout ce qui est important c'est
qu'on arrive à gibraltar dont 10000 407
km 50 km par jour 22 paires de
chaussures une seule ampoule et surtout
mai est surtout un l'impression d'avoir
vraiment fait quelque chose de bien
parce qu'on l'a fait pour nous on a un
réaliser nos rêves
comme vous l'avez vu au début c'est
effectivement quelque chose de très
important pour moi à mes yeux j'espère
je pousse les gens à faire la même chose
à sortir quand je disais de leur zone de
confort et l'ajustement vous voyez j'ai
mangé mon gimont j'ai mon outil qui est
née bien après puisqu'il ya quatre ans
donc ça fait sept ans qu'on a fait ce
périple dont j'ai fait d'autres choses
depuis et l'autre une autre jour c'est
drôle je regardais un film et
un dessin animé avec mon fils est sur ce
dessin animé un mondial personnage qui
dit qui a dit une phrase qui m'avait qui
m'avait marqué c'était il n'ya pas de
rêveurs à ces petits comme il n'ya pas
de rêves assez grand j'espère simplement
qu'il n'oubliera jamais en tout cas je
serai là pour lui rappeler est pour vous
je dirai la même chose aller au bout de
vos rêves
merci